[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to channel awesome
Zorba report your source for everything
happening around the world in pop
culture and entertainment news i'm
heather ruse and i my own wave and this
is your news for Monday May 14th so
first of all we got a trailer this week
for the new predator movie simply titled
the predator um and yeah I mean I'm not
too familiar with the franchise I'm not
gonna lie I'm sorry I'm sorry please
forgive me but I like the designs of the
predator and they looked pretty
interesting
I know it's cliched but I also kind of
found it interesting that it was a child
who seems to have brought of the
predator to our planet although I have
some questions for his parents like why
are you keeping a box of predator
technology in the basement where your
child plays and apparently has access to
a box cutter yeah I mean I found a box
can I start in such easy access to like
open this up and be like oh it's toys I
mean if I found a set like that and I
were a child I would do the same thing
I'd freak out start playing with a query
my parents basement are filled with
costumes I don't play with box cutters
but yeah it looks like it could be
pretty good and we're not gonna have to
wait too long it's after the summer
they'll come to us on September 14th so
I'm sure there is lots more that we have
to look forward to from that movie yeah
I'll be seeing more of it in the future
we also had a bunch of announcements
come out this week including the Captain
Marvel who we've all been wondering what
Carol Danvers has been up to during the
infinity war
and we should find out soon enough
because her own movie just added to its
cast I'm excited it's not confirmed
exactly who she's playing there's been
you know some talks about yeah there's a
lot of rumors she might be a scientist
or a parental figure parent scientist Oh
both we don't know yet it's not
officially confirmed so to wait and see
but I am so stoked yes so soon realize
it's gonna we kick some butt oh thank
you wait to see this movie also in
casting news this week we got news that
Oprah has been cast in a virtual reality
animated shorts called crow the legend
and this actually sounds really
interesting it's a virtual reality short
that's going to be released in two
different parts at least that's the news
about it right now
it's being produced and featuring John
Legend mm-hmm so we've got a lot of
really big names in there and it's gonna
be based off a Native American folk tale
and Oprah has been cast as basically God
I got like the words in them created I
believe it was something like the person
who created everything or something
along those lines is what her character
is being called um which you know I
guess that's just how Oprah sees herself
you know amongst us yeah I mean it
sounds like an interesting project I'll
be excited to see more news about this
as it keeps coming to us yeah we've also
got news on Jordan peels follow-up
to get out we've been waiting and it
looks like we've got a new original
written and directed by him scripts
called us now it's not officially cast
yet there's a few actors in talks and
those
Winston Juke Lupita Nyong'o and that's a
start
I hope those all pool yeah so the story
is gonna be about two couples and it's a
another nightmare apparently according
to the poster that was released and I'm
of course just waiting for it but that's
amazing and I hope they get their fourth
actor for the couple we'll see how that
works out and hopefully that cast is
officially confirmed because I know a
lot of them have been busy and other
things but yeah do this please already
have a release date um it's going to be
produced by monkey paw and come out in
March of 2019 that looks like yeah also
announced this week finally there's
going to be a Bill and Ted three whoa
yes yes enjoy it but we're all over seas
always is finally called Bill and Ted
face the music so I like that that's
that's a pretty fun plan yes that's
going to star our titular characters as
middle-aged men who are kind of settling
into life as parents you know just live
in their life and settling into it when
someone from the future is gonna show up
and tell them that they have to write
the greatest song on earth in order to
save everyone and of course they have to
go on a time-traveling adventure this
time with their daughters yeah it sounds
really intriguing and they already said
there's going to be some new historical
figures involved with this of course we
have Alex winter and Keanu Reeves coming
back to reprise their roles I don't know
who else you would even know dare to
have targets so everyone is on board
super excited this script was written by
the same writers who wrote first two
scripts he's got a lot of the same crew
casts so hopefully it's gonna recapture
some of the magic from the first two
movies
even though it may have been a a while
ago most excellent yeah and we have no
news no so far about when exactly that's
gonna be coming out I don't have a
schedule for it yet just confirmation
it's happening so rejoice yeah yeah
shall we also on a less happy note so
got quite a few cancellations of some
really great television shows this week
like oh my goodness uh for starters
Brooklyn nine-nine of dare you fuck came
out of nowhere
I know no we're not happy about that
now I will say off of that they might
pick it up over on Hulu there's rumors
rumors rumors please do I don't like
what they did with the mini project
where it got canceled off the main
Network right and Hulu picked it up so
do that because when nine-nine is
deserved
he's deserve much like last man on earth
I'm kind of surprised now that was kind
of thing kind of saw that coming and so
they finished off this evening on a
strong note but you know we could have
gotten more with another season so
there's just so much possibilities from
Krishnas also the mick which is a
hilarious show and ended too soon yeah
and also Fox what are you doing
cancelled Lucifer yes well which also
came as a bit of a surprise because they
had kind of left the season off on a
cliffhanger so I guess we're never gonna
get to see the resolution to that
awkward
thanks Fox although you know Fox doesn't
have a great reputation for canceling
shows I kind of do that forget Firefly
yeah I never forget good also recently
announced Quantico has been cancelled as
well and so his designated survivor so a
lot of these seeming like they can't
know
yeah shows that we're doing well or at
least what we thought I mean Twitter is
mad about some of these I've seen my
order you aren't mad it's true yeah I
just I really hope Oakland line is
picked up again I'm yeah kind of just
devastated a lot of people are so good
you know it's not handling well I will
say uh Rick Morty's picked back up 70
episodes so that's not renewed at least
at some point we don't know when that's
a pretty long run yeah have any episodes
so good for them yeah I mean gets it
right like we said you know one day
Harmons a little busy like one that's
gonna be in from us here guys you can
let us know what we missed in the
comments down below or you can reach us
to up to us on its social media
Heather where is that for you you can
find me on Twitter and have the roof's
Instagram at a truce or twitch twitch TV
slash Heather roofs where I stream on
Wednesday nights and you can find me on
Facebook as I gotta wait or everywhere
else as awesome Ayanna that's gonna be
it from us here we will catch you back
here same time same place next week
otherwise the meantime can you beam us
up
[Applause]
you